[Música]
y
durante todo junio la cámara de
representantes de eeuu ha realizado una
serie de audiencias con un solo
propósito reconstruir todo un
rompecabezas de como el entonces
presidente de donald trump tejió una red
de mentiras y depresiones para intentar
revocar las elecciones presidenciales de
2020 con la difusión de falsa
información con una ola de demandas y
luego con un llamado a manifestaciones
en las calles el presidente intentó
sembrar una falsa idea de que hubo
fraude y de que joe biden no había
ganado realmente los comicios el momento
más álgido del intento de trump fue la
toma del capitolio el 6 de enero de 2021
que dejó 5 muertos 14 heridos y lo que
muchos consideran una afrenta a la
democracia de estadounidense por eso la
cámara de representantes- conforman un
comité para investigar cuál fue el papel
de trump en el asalto hasta ahora han
realizado cinco audiencias y las últimas
tres de ellas se han concentrado en la
presión que ejerció el entonces
presidente contra los funcionarios para
intentar convencerlos de que revocarán
las elecciones lo que ocurrió en la
cuarta audiencia
un panorama del papel del mandatario
veamos
la cuarta ronda de audiencias públicas
del comité del 6 de enero la atención se
puso sobre los funcionarios estatales a
quienes donald trump y sus aliados
presionaron repetidamente para que
certificaran la victoria de joe biden
basándose en las teorías conspirativas
de fraude electoral el bando republicano
de trump sabía que eran falsas trump fue
informado por sus propios asesores de
que no tenía ninguna base para sus
afirmaciones de elecciones robadas y
siguió presionando a los funcionarios
estatales para que cambiaran los
resultados en el punto de mira a arizona
donde el presidente de la cámara de
representantes del estado rasti powers
recibe una llamada de tram y su ex
abogado rubí giuliani afirmando
falsamente que miles de migrantes
ilegales y personas muertas habían
votado por you why del más tarde la
abogada de trump john eastman estaba
uers a descertificar a los electores de
su estado al choque nou y volvió a decir
que hice un juramento para mí hacer eso
hacer lo que ustedes hacen sería
contrario a mi juramento magos también
testificaron funcionarios del estado de
georgia incluido el secretario de estado
a quien tran pidió que encontrara los 11
mil 780 votos necesarios para superar el
total d y muchos de los que subieron al
estado relataron una campaña de acoso y
amenazas tras el blanco de trump por su
negativa a anular la elección incluyendo
una trabajadora electoral de georgia y a
su madre
un montón de amenazas deseando la muerte
para mí diciéndome en que ya sabes estar
en la cárcel con mi madre y diciendo
cosas como alégrate de que sea 2020 y no
cuando incluso trató de convencer a los
funcionarios estatales de que aprobara
listas de falsos electores un intento
desesperado de aferrarse al cargo
haciendo temblar los cimientos de la
democracia estadounidense al amenazar el
traspaso pacífico del poder el comité
plantea al menos dos audiencias públicas
más ya que el departamento de justicia
de eeuu debe decidir ahora si presenta o
no cargos penales contra el ex
presidente
para analizar este tema saludamos a lady
jane smith profesora e investigadora del
departamento de economía en la
universidad iberoamericana
ella está en ciudad de méxico también
nos acompaña desde miami rafael peñalver
abogado constitucionalista de eeuu le
recuerdo antes que ustedes también hacen
parte de esta conversación dejen sus
preguntas y comentarios en nuestras
redes sociales estamos en twitter
instagram y facebook en donde nos
encuentran como france24 guión al piso
o en mi cuenta personal mariah que
aguirre en youtube pueden seguir nuestra
señal en vivo y también los invito para
que escuchen el podcast de nuestro
programa estamos en app el podcast
spotify deezer y tuning participen con
el numeral el debate efe 24 y ahora sí
comenzamos nuestra discusión sobre lo
que ha hecho el comité de la cámara de
representantes en eeuu quiero comenzar
entonces con heidi y dándole por
supuesto la bienvenida a nuestro
programa empecemos hablando
políticamente que puede lograr el comité
de la cámara de representantes y cómo se
diferencia su labor de la investigación
que está en el departamento de justicia
y del comité que ya hubo en el senado en
y pues muchas gracias muchas gracias por
la invitación
yo creo que tú punto es muy muy
importante preguntar cuál sería la
ventaja de esas actividades
y sabemos que hay una mayoría de las
transmisiones están viendo estos
juzgados son 26.000 26% de la población
en una encuesta reacción hecha que
siguen seguimientos muy cercanas
a la audiencia y 32 más 32% más entonces
tenemos más que 50% de la población
norteamericana que quiere saber cómo va
y cómo van de seguimiento del juzgado de
este tema tan importante que es un
autogolpe por parte de un ex presidente
de eeuu esos juicios políticos que
estamos revisando son una amenaza de la
democracia norteamericana entonces es
importante de ver no solamente la que la
clase media en la clase grande que si es
que quiere la democracia y que vean la
democracia cómo funciona y sigue siendo
una de las democracias
fuerte y que pueda entender
rafael peñalver y también le quiero
transmitir esta pregunta cuáles son los
alcances del comité y sobre todo quiero
decirle que éste está conformado por
nueve legisladores ninguno de ellos es
pro trump y los únicos dos republicanos
que hacen parte fueron elegidos por
nancy pelosi la líder de los demócratas
en la cámara baja en este sentido que
tan parcializado puede ser entonces el
comité
manejar primero muchas gracias por la
invitación un gusto compartir contigo y
con jaydy en este en este momento tan
histórico estamos viendo precisamente un
un evento que quedará para siempre en la
historia norteamericana
como una de las de las traiciones más
grandes que se le intentó hacer al país
y aquí está un comité de la cámara de
representantes- tratando de conseguirlo
anteriormente es un rompecabezas tan tan
grande tratando de que el pueblo
norteamericano sepa exactamente lo que
sucedió el 6 de enero fue simplemente la
culminación de una conspiración la
conspiración de que comenzó muchos meses
antes incluso antes de que se celebrara
las elecciones ya el presidente en
tromba estaba diciendo de que si él
perdía las elecciones era porque se
había hecho fraude y ahí se empezó a
montar una situación tan tan grande que
fue primero que nada decir que hubo
fraude es decir que había ganado
en realidad había perdido segundo tratar
de convencer al pueblo norteamericano de
esa gran mentira después presionar a los
registradores y terminando con la
presión que se acusó al vicepresidente
para que tratar de cambiar que los votos
electorales de todos los estados que
había perdido se cambiarán y que se
impusieran electores que favorecieran al
presidente de trump engañando al pueblo
americano que salieran a las calles que
fueran a washington el día 6 de enero
presentando un grupo de personas que ya
tenían en mente asaltar al capitolio y
el propósito de todo esto era parar el
conteo que era la culminación del
proceso electoral norteamericano es el
conteo de los electores el día 6 de
enero y todo el plan era que eso no
sucediera para que le diera tronco más
tiempo para seguir poniendo presiones
para seguir tratando de quedarse en el
poder a pesar de que él sabía que había
perdido una elección como usted dice
rafael
el capitolio fue el último episodio de
un plan que venía desde antes y a
propósito el 4 de noviembre declaró la
victoria de las elecciones a pesar de
que sus asesores le dijeron que no lo
hiciera como lo reveló el comité que más
ha dicho este grupo de legisladores de
las advertencias de los asesores
que las las audiencias han sido
devastadoras para el presidente trompa
algo que aquí se está demostrando punto
por punto día por día hora por hora está
este comité ha entrevistado a más de mil
personas es algo extraordinario la forma
en que se está presentando este caso y
la importancia de esto yo no sé si a mí
se van a presentar cargos criminales o
no eso es una cuestión que el
departamento de justicia y el fiscal
general tendrá que decidir este comité
del congreso no tiene poder para
encausar a nadie pero sí es importante
que quede ante la historia lo que
sucedió aquí para que esto no se repita
y la razón que te digo que x es no se
sabe si van a presentar cargos o no no
es porque no hayan los los datos
necesarios para encauzar al presidente a
tromba es claro que existen los datos
para encauzarlo por muchas cosas pero la
razón por la cual quizás no se haga es
por el bien del país igual que cuando
nixon renunció se le dio un perdón para
que el país no tuviera que atravesar por
un proceso tan doloroso que va a demorar
dos años y que al final se le va a
presentar a un curado y que solamente un
miembro del jurado que diga que no se
encuentre culpable será suficiente para
exonerar al presidente trump así que es
una situación que hay que valorar
primero si no se hace nada
que qué elección tan tan mala para la
historia que es que un presidente pueda
intentar de dar un golpe de estado y que
después no se le acuse de un cargo
criminal si se le acusa en un cargo
criminal es difícil para el país tener
que atravesar por este proceso así que
lo que lo que ha hecho tonta para este
país es un daño tan grande para la
democracia americana y para la imagen de
eeuu ante los ojos del mundo que no hay
nada no hay nada parecido en la historia
de este país
y usted coincide con esta postura de
rafael de que las audiencias han sido
devastadoras incluso a pesar de que
pueda que no haya consecuencias penales
contra trump
eso es y eso es un poco más complicado
yo creo que más allá de la audiencia de
más allá de las entrevistas que haya hay
que pensar y si condenamos nos
condenamos a la onu trump
también tiene que ver con una necesidad
fuerte de más pectorales que necesitamos
dentro del eeuu como la forma que
trabajamos es de las elecciones las
reglas de las xxi y cómo manejamos por
la parte a que son normas en realidad y
no son leyes en muchos países el mercado
de cine tiene leyes mucho más
específicos de cómo seleccionan y cómo
sea la democracia en sus países y
quienes asumen tablet mente siempre
hemos tenido una muy buena fe en la
confianza del sistema y donde las cosas
no notarios de lo que hemos estado
escuchando y hemos aprendido desde la
instancia de que trump salió con la mega
mentira que hizo es que hay mucha
universidad de reformas electorales
hacia la selección de cómo han
brindarnos en él
en nuestra democracia y cómo funciona la
democracia dentro de esta ciudad y
quiero hacerle otra pregunta y es que al
inicio de todo este aparataje electoral
trump inició dos campañas primero empezó
a hablar de fraude y segundo sus
abogados y sus seguidores interpusieron
60 demandas aunque sólo una prosperó
tuvo una gran derrota legal sin embargo
explíquenos como caló en los
estadounidenses que trump hablara de
fraude y que hubiera esta ola de
demandas
pero lo que pasa es que las listas
electorales son extra estatales la gente
realmente piense que los eeuu es una
democracia nacional en realidad es una
democracia federalista enlace de
relación significa que cada uno de los
estados tiene su propio partido político
que ocean's gmt hablamos de que hay dos
partidos políticos por tan socios pero
en realidad son 102 porque porque cada
estado tiene su propio partido político
que escojan las candidatos de entre el
estado en y ahí se nombran sus
representantes al colegio electoral
entonces desde y desde entonces tenemos
un sistema electoral ya bastante de sanz
articulado dentro de quién son las
personas que afectan cuáles son los
electorales cuáles son cuáles son los
puntos de vista de la campaña y cuáles
son los partidos políticos entonces
muchas veces conocen un norteamericano y
tienen dice que son de un partido pero
si hablas de otra persona de otro estado
dice que está en el mismo partido y
tienen opiniones muy distintas es que
necesitan una norteamericana por parte
de su política es muy articulada muy
descentralizada entonces las 60
propuestas tuvieron que manejar todas
las están aclaradas pero además el
sistema de justicia
dentro de cada uno de los estados
entonces aunque uno de los 60 fue medio
verdad entonces tuvieron que ver dentro
del sistema de justicia para asegurar
que cumplían o cumplido con la verdad
entonces de los
90 días posterior de la selección
eso dejó trump para poner su gran
mentira de que era había fraude cuando
no había fraude entonces han dado que
eeuu es que hay que buscar la evidencia
para confirmar que no es verdad
la búsqueda está confiada de la
confirmación dejó tiempo para que
hiciera esta campaña de no verdad toda
gran mentira y ese gran mentira aumentó
un montón de dinero que era más
muchísimo dinero para la campaña la
campaña no republicana la campaña de la
gran mentira y desde ahí entonces me
impulsan el movimiento de escoger las
que buscan la gente para llevar al cabo
la autogolpe del 6 de enero sí y ahí
quiero hacer una precisión la gran
mentira a la que usted se refiere es el
término que ha usado el comité de la
cámara de representantes para referirse
a toda esta estrategia de trump de
revocar los resultados y a pesar de la
fragmentación estatal de la que nos
habla haydee hubo un papel federal
determinante que fue el del
vicepresidente
mike pence quien su labor cuya labor era
certificar la victoria que ya le había
dado desde diciembre el colegio
electoral a joe biden a propósito de
esto la tercera audiencia del comité fue
dedicada a demostrar como trump presionó
a pence para que no certificar a esa
victoria yo le quiero preguntar a rafael
qué pasó cómo se probó que los asesores
de trump le pidieron una pena que no
certificará y cómo se reconstruyó ese
día
el corte ha estado entrevistando a uno
por uno de los asesores del presidente y
del vicepresidente
especialmente el jefe de la
administración de la oficina del
vicepresidente
tendió una evidencia increíble donde
todo lo que sucedió cómo fue que le
toque sabiendo sabiendo que el plan que
le estaban proponiendo era
inconstitucional dos abogados el abogado
iván y el abogado giuliano le pusieron
presión y presión y presión al
vicepresidente para que tratará por
todos los medios de que cuando llegara
el momento del conteo el día 6 de enero
el conteo electoral que el
vicepresidente
opusiera el conteo diciendo de que había
dudas sobre algunos estados o
simplemente que escogiera otro grupo de
electores que favorecieran a trump en
lugar del grupo de electores que habían
enviado los distintos estados
reflejando el voto popular en esos
estados así que la presión que le
pusieron a apenas fue fue por todos los
lados
tepames estuvo cuatro años
siguiendo el plan de la administración
de trump actuando como un súbdito en
muchas cosas nunca tuvo una voz
independiente pero hay que darle crédito
que gracias a pace se salvó la
democracia norteamericana el día 6 de
enero porque a pesar de todas las
menciones que le pusieron incluyendo
amenazas de muerte él dijo lo que se me
pide que yo haga yo no lo puedo hacer
que es parar el conteo para buscarlas
una forma de que trump y él como
vicepresidente
siguieran en el poder hay que darle el
programa de crédito y darle las gracias
al país porque en ese momento histórico'
defendió la constitución y salvó la
democracia norteamérica y justo como
ustedes dice en las audiencias se reveló
que el presidente de trump tuvo una
llamada telefónica compense ese 6 de
enero en la mañana y lo llamó cobarde
luego la turba intentó ahorcar o dijo
que quería ahorcar al vicepresidente y
tal como lo dice rafael el comité
retrato ap es como un héroe de la
democracia que arriesgó incluso su
propia vida para seguir los lineamientos
y no ceder a la presión de trump aidico
heteros cuál es la intención de los
demócratas al resaltar a algunos
republicanos y diferenciarlos
abiertamente de trump
pues claro si hay algunos republicanos
están más alineados a la línea de trump
diciendo que tenía verdad la gran
mentira y que hay que seguir seguir una
nueva versión de los votos no eran
calificadas y no cuenta contaba en todos
los esfuerzos de salvar a la república y
algunos pusieron el partido encima de la
república
eso nos escuchamos un poco de guía por
parte de ambas tables que fue el
secretario de de la razón ese estado de
elecciones donde también había presiones
para firmar el voto de una forma u otro
y el señor dijo que en su testimonio que
su juramento hacía más a la construcción
y adiós que un partido político entonces
eso también se refleja en la búsqueda de
dividir el partido republicano en los
jugadores de trump y no jugadores de
trump entonces lo últimas noticias que
hemos tenido en términos de más eliminar
es de los
votos para seleccionar los candidatos
para ahora en los medianos la acción
selecciones de medios de noviembre pero
también para quién sería el candidato en
2024 entonces estamos viendo a
lineamientos del nuevo vencimiento de
las personas que creen no creen en gran
mentira y obviamente los que creen a la
gran mentira son los castigadores de
trump y lo que hemos visto en los votos
es que no siempre ganan en sus las
elecciones y rara vez ganan los que son
seguidores de trump entonces hay una
quiebra dentro del partido republicana
en términos de
los que son una gran mentira y los que
no son la
representante de extensión republicana
admirable de lanzar y proponer la
candidatura de ponerla en el comité y el
comité está haciendo su trabajo en
llamar la atención al atentado de la
doble golpe que hubo el cese del 6 de
enero y antes de seguir profundizando en
el impacto que esto tendrá en las
elecciones que hablaremos de esto un
poco después quiero preguntarle al señor
rafael por la presión ejercida contra el
departamento de justicia william bar que
era del entonces fiscal general anunció
su renuncia el 14 de diciembre justo el
mismo día en el que los colegios
electorales
oficializaron la victoria de joe biden
además el comité de la cámara de
representantes ha señalado otra
estrategia de trump y que fue presionar
al fiscal interino jeffrey browser e
incluso intentándolo reemplazarlo rafael
que tan importante era el departamento
de justicia para ratificar o tumbar la
mentira de trump de que le habían robado
las elecciones y porque él yo intentaba
poner a la cabeza a alguien que
estuviera de su lado
porque él está esa línea que la había
perdido que todo esto es un fraude que
todo es todo un invento pero la hacía
falta que el departamento de justicia le
diera credibilidad y lo intento hacer
pidiéndole al fiscal general que enviara
una carta a cuatro o cinco estados donde
el trump alegaba que se había que en el
que ya se habían se había hecho fraude y
con esa carta diciendo de que el
departamento de justicia que estaba
investigando posibles fraudes en esos
estados cosas que era mentira porque el
departamento de justicia había hecho una
investigación y había encontrado que no
había fraude eso se lo había comunicado
personalmente el fiscal general bajar a
tron el día 30 de diciembre y a pesar de
eso trump seguía insistiendo de que de
que se dijera que él había ganado y que
el departamento de justicia le dieran
credibilidad a esas declaraciones cuando
el fiscal general dijo que él no se
prestaría a eso y renunció var renuncia
el día 15 de diciembre porque no se
quería
a eso
nombran al nuevo fiscal general trump le
pide a un nuevo fiscal general que le
mande la carta a los estados cuando él
también se niega a firmar esa carta
trump lo amenaza con destituirlos y ahí
es cuando todos los asistentes del
departamento todos los asistentes al
fiscal general dicen si usted hace eso
nosotros todos presenciamos sería como
lo que hizo en la hembra de nexo ver el
famoso más la más famosa masacre del
desde el sábado por la noche ahí fue
donde trump se para le coge miedo al
hacer eso pero sigue adelante sigue
adelante con el plan de poner la presión
al vicepresidente pensé de traer a miles
y miles de personas de todas partes del
país a esa gran demostración del día 6
de enero y tratar de impedir que se
hiciera que el conteo electoral esto ha
sido un golpe de estado de verdad creo
que ha demostrado como decía jaime
anteriormente
frágil es la democracia norteamericana
aquí estamos basados un país tan grande
tan poderoso y sin embargo la base que
es la democracia está basada en unas mba
principalmente en la buena fe del pueblo
en la buena fe de sus oficiales porque
las leyes en sí son mínimas son
tradiciones que se siguen y trump tras
acabó a cabo con todas él no tenía el
más mínimo aprecio por lo que la
democracia norteamericana había logrado
en casi 250 años de desarrollo vio lo
frágil que era pensó que es una
república bananera que no se dicen
respectivamente en este país y pensó que
podía permanecer en el poder simplemente
con un juego de fichas a muy alto nivel
y por poco lo logra por todos los logros
por eso como bien dice jaime hay que
buscar reformas en las leyes de las
elecciones norteamericanas para que esto
jamás vuelva a suceder y para hacer un
recuento de lo que hemos hablado ya
hemos entonces como donald trump intentó
revocar los resultados electorales
primero declarando una victoria que no
tenía luego promocionando que se parara
el robo electoral que no existía
implementando una serie de demandas que
fracasaron y luego presionando al
departamento de justicia y al
vicepresidente mike pence para que
tumbaran esas elecciones en las que
biden había ganado y es así como
llegamos al 6 de enero de 2021 el día
del ataque al capitolio una de las
pruebas más conocidas contra trump es un
tuit que él mismo publicó en el que
llamó a las manifestaciones en frente
del legislativo el mismo día que pensé
iba a certificar la victoria de byd en
round le pidió a quienes protestaban que
fueran salvajes esto de manera literal
haydee que tanto influyó otro hombre los
manifestantes para que se tomaran el
capitolio violentamente y usted está de
acuerdo con lo que dice rafael de que
esto fue un golpe de estado y de que
trump creía en una república paralela
si en siete políticas utilizamos la
plana autogolpe como era encargado ya
como presidente nombrado como presidente
y llamas sus propios partidos político
propio grupo de gente viendo al capítulo
de y es un autogolpe porque el mismo
está tratando de copiar el propio estado
para su cargo entonces obviamente son
muchas leyes que se rompieron y no no
o presiones o formas de ver pero en
cualquier forma es hasta la propia hija
tenemos testimonio del primer y segundo
día de la armoniosa y en el congreso que
dice que yo no quise que siguiera mi
papá había unos cuatro señores de lan
que el dinero día de seis dinero que se
fue a la casa blanca y no escuchamos
nada de él después del correo bueno el
texto de tui que mandó y luego regresa y
al final del día él dice bueno hay que
retirarse pero cuando ya pidió la retiro
de su gente ya había hecho búsquedas de
los individuos
no solamente su vicepresidente que la
quieren copiar y también la jefa del del
congreso a mí ni al tipo dos y entre
otras personas más
estos son no son cuestiones democráticas
eso no son la forma de tratar las
instituciones democráticas eso es una
forma de buscar su propio
poder y vengan del sistema entonces eso
tiene muchas preocupaciones por qué
depende cómo sigue
eso es estos testimonios si están
buscados para cómo vamos a proceder por
servir en la siguiente elección y otro
de los temas que se discutirán en las
audiencias es que cuando la turba se
tomó el capitolio durante horas tron se
quedó en silencio y no pidió parar la
violencia rafael explíquenos que hizo o
que no hizo el entonces presidente
durante el ataque lo que hizo
principalmente fue que en el momento en
que rompen las filas de los policías y
penetran el café al capitolio aquella
turba en ese momento trump en lugar de
pedir calma en lugar de pedir que
aquella violencia terminada lo que hace
que manda un tweet diciendo de que el
vicepresidente temps no había cumplido
con sus con lo que se esperaba de él y
que dándole dándole estímulo aquella
aquella turba para que fueran a buscar a
pez que es cuando entonces le empiezan a
gritar vamos a colgar a pence juzguemos
a page sangre and jane entonces esa fue
la reacción de un presidente que por el
resto de la tarde esto pasó más de dos
horas y media
viendo aquella violencia que le costó la
vida a cinco personas y no fue ni
siquiera para [__] el teléfono y pedir
calma pedir y condenar aquello al
contrario él lo que quería es que se
formara el caos para que no pudiera
seguir adelante el conteo de los votos
electorales hubo que suspender la sesión
pero heróicamente a las tres de la
mañana de esa noche el congreso volvió
al capitolio y entre todos aquellos
escombros en las las las salas llenas de
cristales rotos se confirmó la victoria
se tomó la votación y se confirmó la
victoria de 20
el trump no logró lo que quería esa
noche no logró parar la certificación no
paró el traspaso pacífico del poder a
pesar de sus mejores esfuerzos y ahora
el país está pagando las consecuencias
ojalá ojalá que ese 30 por ciento de
personas que todavía lo sigue aprendan
una lección y para mí una de las
cuestiones más increíbles de todo esto
es que todavía haya personas que sigan a
trump la mejor frase de todas estas
audiencias yo creo que la tuvo la
representante liz jane el primer día y
dijo
pasará pero la deshonra de aquellas
personas que nos siguen apoyando
permanecerá para siempre y eso del país
rafael quiero preguntarle por un tema
que haydee ya tocó anteriormente y es el
impacto que tendrán estas audiencias en
las elecciones de medio término en
noviembre donde a pesar de que donald
trump no se presenta como uno de los
candidatos los demócratas se juegan la
escasa mayoría o la estrecha mayoría que
tienen en el congreso cómo podría
impactar esto en esas elecciones de
medio término y también en las
presidenciales de 2024
yo creo que todo esto todavía
queda mucha evidencia por presentar pero
está teniendo un impacto enorme si tú
ves las encuestas el apoyo hacia el
trump se ha ido reduciendo en forma en
forma muy significante en los en las
últimas semanas cuando más y más se sabe
de estas desde el ocurrido pero más
importante para las elecciones de
noviembre va a ser los temas económicos
la inflación el alza en el precio de la
gasolina en la violencia son todos temas
se estamos pasando por un momento
difícil en el país los demócratas no
tienen la tradición no de que el partido
que está en el poder
tradicionalmente pierde escaños en las
elecciones de medio término así que en
toda probabilidad los republicanos ganan
escaños aunque no se sabe cuánto desde
en qué cantidad debido a la situación
tan difícil porque atraviesa el país la
guerra de ucrania todas estas
situaciones van montando para lo que
debe ser un una victoria republicana sin
embargo yo creo que después de esta
audiencia vamos a empezar a ver a muchos
de los oficiales públicos que hasta
ahora habían estado apoyando a trump ver
cómo se salen de ese tren como se conoce
se saltan de ese barco que se está
hundiendo y no me sorprendería que de
aquí a noviembre sucedieran cosas que
incluye inclusive el posible
encausamiento aunque yo creo que sí hay
encausamiento vendrá después de
noviembre a nivel federal es posible que
venga un encauzamiento a nivel estatal
en el estado de georgia y que eso ocurra
antes ya en el estado de georgia se está
trabajando un gran jurado al que se le
está presentando evidencia que puede ser
es que encaucen a trump por el intento
que hizo de presionar a los oficiales
del estado de georgia a encontrar los 11
mil 780 votos que le hacían falta para
ganar el estado de georgia algo que es
totalmente
inmoral e ilegal que un presidente coge
el teléfono y se pasea una hora y 10
minutos presionando a un oficial de ese
estado para que haga una ilegalidad una
cosa tan tan tan mala como los que
cambian los resultados de un mes tras la
quinta audiencia de los legisladores
republicanos pidieron un indulto
preventivo para trump por el asalto al
capitolio explíquenos que es esta figura
y cuáles serían las consecuencias
el indulto preventivo es una señal de
que estás preocupado de que has hecho
algo ilegal y estás pidiendo entonces
que se tengan un perdón o indulto
preventivo para que no puedan presentar
cargos en contra tuya eso han hecho
algunos registradores aparentemente lo
hizo el propio abogado
trump el que inventó todo está todo este
escenario desde que pensó podía cambiar
el resultado el doctor osman antes de
que terminara la presidencia le pidió
que le diera un perdón preventivo
indulto preventivo y también hay algunos
legisladores que los que se lo pidieron
igual tú no pides un indulto únicamente
que tú creas que tú has hecho algo
ilegal y el aceptaron perdón el hecho de
que tú aceptes un perdón indica que tú
eres culpable
suprema de eeuu ha sido muy claro en eso
quien acepte un poco es culpable de
haití y quiero terminar con usted una
breve recuento de cuáles son los
impactos de estas audiencias muy
brevemente explíquenos
claro en siempre hablamos de los meten a
las elecciones a medio año entre las
presidencias que sería ahora en 2020 2
noviembre y hablamos en la cámara baja
la cámara del congreso
el senado y el senado es donde siempre
ha sido muy dividido lo que pasa es que
muchos de los asientos no son por
población son por por estados que
definen el voto y la división dentro del
congreso dentro del senado el 50 se
encuentra ahorita entonces el
vicepresidente es quien decide
y
fue lo mismo contra habitantes que
también tomó la posición de decidir el
voto último para para el empate y ahora
en 2022 tenemos que thor 600 que son
abiertas para las elecciones para los
demócratas y 21 cientos para los
republicanos
muchas veces la tendencia democrática y
republicanos pero tendencia es que hay
un control peso del poder dentro de los
niños
en las elecciones de medio corto que se
seleccionan a otro partido y yo creo que
este año estamos en la situación donde
puede ser que no seguimos la televisión
puede ser que hay suficiente enojo que
hay suficiente que no va a seguir en
2024 unos años y cristian porque son 20
asientos para los demócratas y 10 para
los republicanos entonces sigue también
en juego muchos asientos hacia qué
políticas se va a ir al partido y que
comienza se voy a interrumpir ya veremos
qué pasa en el 2024
haydee jane smith gracias por estar con
nosotros
intenta dar muchas gracias
rafael peñalver muchas gracias por estar
aquí en france 24
y así llegamos al final del debate pero
sigan ustedes aquí con más información
internacional
[Música]